well ladies and gentlemen he did it last
night a wet and glistening Donald Trump
announced his 2024 presidential run to a
crowd of sort of bored people quite
frankly that's one of the story lines
from Mar-A-Lago which we'll get to a
little bit later but a very different
energy last night than in times past
Trump himself even seemed kind of bored
with the speech he was reading off of
his teleprompter the crowd only engaged
at a few moments and remember that many
people around Trump were telling him as
recently as Monday you should not do
this you should not do this after the
results of the 2022 midterms you should
not do this after the realization that
this isn't even really over 2022
elections until December 6 with the
runoff in Georgia and Donald Trump
deciding to do it now many of you will
remember our friend Michael Cohen
Trump's former lawyer swore up and down
to me Trump's not gonna run many others
even in my audience were emailing me as
recently as yesterday morning saying
Trump's not going to run he is running
and we are now going to have another
potentially two years of insanity in the
United States now before we get to the
clips another aspect to this that I
believe especially with the energy
behind Ron DeSantis may be very
different than in 2016 and in 2020 is
that you are going to see the people
behind Donald Trump especially those who
get behind him this early on average be
even more extreme because there are now
other options including Ron DeSantis who
hasn't declared that he's running for
anything and is already leading Trump in
most polls taken after the November 8th
midterms all of which we will get to CNN
and Fox News initially covered Trump's
speech live
uh they eventually cut away we're going
to get to that as well MSNBC ignored it
completely I tried to cover it we had
technical issues which I will address a
little bit later I got some really nasty
emails about it but I will get to that
but let's start off with already I mean
just even the way Donald Trump was
welcomed into the room was absurd
Gentlemen please welcome the next
president and first lady of the United
States of America
president Donald J Trump accompanied by
Mrs Melania Trump
Adam
American okay so just completely
horrifying from the get-go the most high
energy moment from the entire thing was
the moment that Donald Trump actually
announced
in order to make America great and
glorious again I am tonight announcing
my candidacy for president of the United
States
okay so the crowd certainly engaged
there but at almost no other time Donald
Trump was expected to go at the most
half an hour he went nearly a full hour
and got into some of the same old tired
stuff including this completely Bonkers
dictatorial idea of executing every drug
dealer like they do in China responsible
for death Carnage and crime all over our
country every drug dealer during his or
her life on average will kill 500 people
with the drugs they sell not to mention
the destruction of families
but we're going to be asking everyone
who sells drugs gets caught selling
drugs to receive the death penalty for
their heinous acts even that language is
so funny we're going to ask the drug
dealers to receive the death penalty uh
Mr drug dealer sir we would like you to
receive the death penalty please because
it's the only way
we don't need any more Blue Ribbon
committees we don't need I don't like to
say this and I don't even know of the
American public is ready for it and a
lot of my people say please don't say
that sir that's not nice they kill 500
people each on average
and if you don't do this in China when I
was with President XI I said president
do you have a drug problem no no no no
no we don't he looked at that's Trump's
uh impersonation of she no no no no no
no so listen this is a this is a wacky
idea and again not mincing words this is
an authoritarian extremist he would like
the United States to be even more
authoritarian but he's also a liar and a
hypocrite because Donald Trump pardoned
many drug dealers at the end of his
presidency so death penalty for drug
dealers also Trump pardoning drug
dealers at another moment during the
speech clearly gearing up for what is
going to be a contentious battle with
other Republicans it's abundantly clear
that's going to be the case during this
new presidential run Donald Trump
actually sort of going after the
Republican party but laying out a very
Bleak situation much criticism is being
placed on the fact that the Republican
Party should have done better and
frankly much of this blame is correct
but the citizens of our country have not
yet realized the full extent and gravity
of the pain our nation is going through
and the total effect of the suffering is
just starting to take hold you're going
to suffer much much more ladies and
gentlemen but you can also vote for me
and I'll fix everything even though I
fixed nothing last time and this is part
of why I think this time it may not go
so well for Trump but we'll get to that
don't quite feel it yet but they will
very soon I have no doubt that by 2024
it will sadly be much worse and they
will see much more clearly what happened
and what is happening to our country
Yeah by by the time you get the
opportunity to vote for me Trump says
things are really going to be bad
another kind of weird interlude and a
strange thing to include in a
presidential announcement Trump's saying
again that we're going to go to Mars at
least he pronounced it correctly this
time remember that Viral moment
previously where Trump said we are going
to put a man on Nars he at least got it
right this time human knowledge and
extend the horizons of human achievement
and we will plant our beautiful American
flag very soon on the surface of Mars
which I got started the crowd is sort of
like yeah I guess so Trump said he got
that started which is of course not true
a very weird thing Trump also choosing
to float a new conspiracy theory during
this announcement that maybe China is
the one that stole the 2020 elections
from him remember he's tried everything
else it was the Democrats it was
Communist communist Communists
Communists socialists marxists all of
whom don't really exist in the United
States uh it was you know Hunter Biden's
laptop but whatever now it's and this is
very irresponsible now it might have
been China many people think that
because of this China played a very
active role
in the 2020 election just saying just
say
sure that didn't happen
all right you know like two people
clapping and what is becoming very clear
about this new run which of course it
will be another grift run for Trump to
raise money is the strategy will be lie
about all the things he he supposedly
did as president claim everything was
amazing when he was president
and then claimed that again we need him
to prevent things from being terrible
which they will be under Joe Biden I
guess at another moment I I know guys
it's you you look at the calendar and
you say
is is my calendar right is it November
of 2022 is it almost 2023 and Trump is
still talking about Hillary Clinton's
emails which he by the way pronounces
Clinton which is a whole other story yes
you would be right he's still talking
about that include
in close right here
Bush's Place why didn't you rate Clinton
thousand emails why didn't you rate
Clinton's place what and you do
Obama who took a lot of things with him
yeah
so I didn't know I know Trump claims to
be religious and we know that he's not
maybe this is the Festivus airing of
grievances that Donald Trump was doing
and he did indeed straight up just say
I'm a victim I'm a very big victim thank
you
I'm a victim I will tell you I'm a
victim think of it uh thank you
surprising to some but not to others
Donald Trump did include portions of the
transphobic sections of his recent rally
speeches in his big announcement
yesterday pay attention to something is
notable about this part we were doing we
were starting to really get it right we
will not let men as an example
participate in women's sports is that
okay no way no men no men
now the crowd is engaged
my people tell me sure that's
Politically Incorrect to say I said
that's okay I'll say it anyway if you
don't mind
so much like with CPAC recently
the transphobia and homophobia were the
most interesting moments of CPAC
speeches to that crowd
other than when Trump said I'm running
for president this was in our speech the
crowd was mostly dead dead they tried to
leave they weren't allowed we'll get to
that
um the most interesting moments of the
speech to the crowd were when Trump said
I'm running and when Trump said no men
in women's sports so that tells us quite
a bit one other thing Donald Trump
blamed the green New Deal for all sorts
of things there is no green New Deal the
green New Deal isn't law it's just a
proposal really bad
the Socialist disaster known as the
Green New Deal which is destroying our
country and the many crippling
regulations that it has spawned
will be immediately terminated so that
our country can again breathe and grow
and Thrive like it should
yeah the crowd maybe with tepid Applause
because there is no green New Deal to
end the green New Deal is a proposal
but the green new deal is not the law so
the crowd clearly confused and then
here's the end of Donald Trump's speech
the crowd just barely into it Trump
doing you know a version of the same way
he's ended his recent rally speeches
we will make America strong again
we will make America proud again
we will make America safe again
we will make America glorious again
that's a little extra addition
and we will make America great again
thank you very much God bless you all
thank you yeah
so listen
um a very different speech than at any
prior time this is going to be a very
different sort of candidacy for Donald
Trump there are options there are strong
options there are many Republicans who
are already sick of this guy
and and and and
there is a completely different dynamic
in the United States with what the
Republican Party electorate looks like
so this is only the beginning we are
going to be with you for the entire
thing 2024 clearly Starts Now earlier
than ever the best thing you can do make
sure you're subscribed to our podcast
make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel and be with us for the
coverage and we will see where the
country ends up there are more than
three million viewers of ours who watch
the clips but aren't subscribed on
YouTube make sure you hit that subscribe
button it's a very easy thing to do
parents in the audience if you're like
me you're looking for fun new things to
do with your kids meaningful enriching
but fun enough to keep them engaged
every month our sponsor Mel science
sends you a box with science experiments
that combine Hands-on Physical
components with virtual and augmented
reality learning science doesn't need to
be boring it doesn't need to be
difficult many kids are Hands-On
Learners who absorb the most through
activities like these it's perfect for
homeschooling ages 5 through High School
five different subscriptions to choose
from chemistry physics stem math or
medicine Mel science sent me the
chemistry of monsters box where you grow
a black monster from sugar and make a
huge foam eruption in a flask but you're
actually learning about carbon dioxide
and unstable carbonic acid we had a ton
of fun with it the VR components are
awesome too it is really clear how this
helps kids tune into what they are
learning and my audience gets 50 off
your first month go to melscience.com
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below